>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
THE ONLY THING WE'RE
BROADCASTING -- HELLO.
LIVE AT 2022 PATRIOT AWARDS IN
HOLLYWOOD.
IS THIS A FREE STATE HERE?
TIME IS OVER AND ENDED WITH THE
BIG LOSS.
>> JOE BIDEN LONG ACCUSED OF
CORRUPTION AND HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP FROM HELL AND BIDEN SOLD
ACCESS TO HIGHEST LEVELS OF
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO AMERICA'S
FOREIGN ADVERSARIES AND
COUNTRIES THAT HATE US.
DO WE HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES THAT'S COMPROMISED
AND OF COURSE HE ENDED UP USING
HIS CRACK ADDICTED SON AS A BAG
MAN.
HUNTER BIDEN WITH NO EXPERIENCE
COLLECTED MILLIONS FROM THE
FORMER FIRST LADY OF MOSCOW.
THEN $100 MILLION INVESTMENT
FROM HIM AND HER AND RELATES TO
REAL ESTATE AND OF COURSE THEY
GOT MONEY FROM UKRAINE.
HUNTSER WENT ON GOOD MORNING
AMERICA AND ANY EXPERIENCE IN
OIL, GAS, ENERGY.
WHY DO YOU THINK HE MADE
MILLIONS?
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE BECAUSE OF YOUR FATHER.
DUPESES OF NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND DUNSES OF
COUNTRIES AND ACCORDING TO
HUNTER HIMSELF, A CUT OF THE
PROCEEDS WAS ALWAYS SET ASIDE
FOR THE BIG GUY.
TEXT FOUND ON HUNTER'S LAPTOP
AND HAD TO COMPLAIN ABOUT GIVING
UP HALF OF HIS INCOME TO POPS
AND PAID FOR UPKEEP ON JOE'S
MENTION IN DELAWARE AND JOE
BIDEN DENIED ANY KNOWLEDGE OF
HIS SON'S BUSINESS DEALS OR EVER
EVEN TALKING TO HIS SON ABOUT
HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'VE NEVER DISCUSSED THE
BUSINESS DEALINGS AND THAT'S THE
SAME THING WE DID IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION.
AN ABSOLUTE WALL BETWEEN
PERSONAL AND PRIVATE GOVERNMENT.
>> DO YOU STAND BY YOUR
STATEMENT YOU DID NOT DISCUSS
ANY OF YOUR SON'S OVERSEAS
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> YES, I STAND BY THAT
STATEMENT.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN LIED TO THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY AND IN PHOTOGRAPH
AFTER PHOTOGRAPH AFTER
PHOTOGRAPH HE WAS PICTURED HAD
HIS SON'S BUSINESS PARTNERS AND
EVIDENCE THAT JOE MET WITH AT
LEAST 14 OF THE INDIVIDUALS JUST
BETWEEN 2010 AND 2018 ALONE.
NOW THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS WILL
BE DEMANDING ANSWERS.
>> IN 2019 AFTER ANNOUNCES
CAMPAIGN FOR PRESIDENT, JOE
BIDEN TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAD HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH AND
NEVER HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH HIS
FAMILY ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
THAT WAS A LIE.
THE BIDENS BECAME BILLIONAIRES
BY OFFERING ACCESS TO THE
FAMILY.
AMONG THE DOZENS OF SHELL
COMPANIES THAT BIDEN SET UP,
THERE WERE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF WIRE TRANSFERS, FLIGHTS ON
AIR FORCE 2 TO CONDUCT PERSONAL
BUSINESS AND MEETINGS WITH HEADS
OF STATE ALL WHILE JOE BIDEN WAS
AWARE OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION OF JOE
BIDEN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND WHY HE LIED ABOUT THE
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS SCHEMES.
>> Sean: NOW THE WHITE HOUSE,
THEY'RE CALLING THIS A LONG
DEBUNKED CONSPIRACY THEORY BUT
WE KNOW BETTER.
THE PICTURES ARE REAL AND LAPTOP
FROM HELL IS REAL AND HUNTER'S
BUSINESS ASSOCIATES ARE REAL AND
ONE OF THOSE BUSINESS ASSOCIATES
TONY BOBULINSKI WILL JOIN US
HERE ONSET IN A BIT.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN DESCRIBED
THIS IS ANYTHING BUT A DE-BUNT
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> IT CHANGED AND IT WAS NOT HIS
LAP TO THE.
WELL, IT'S HIS LAPTOP BUT IT'S
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION REMEMBER
AND NO ONE DID ANYTHING WRONG.
THEN IT WAS, WELL, MAYBE, MAYBE
ME DID SOMETHING WRONG BUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT AND NOW IT'S MAYBE
PRESIDENT BIDEN KNEW ABOUT IT
AND WAS INVOLVED BUT IT DIDN'T
INFLUENCE HIS DECISIONS.
>> Sean: HOW MUCH WENT UP IN
SMOKE AND FOREIGN INVESTORS AND
POLITICIANS AND DON'T GIVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO A CRACK
HEAD FOR NO REASON.
IN GOES BEYOND THE BIDENS AND
WHITE HOUSE AND THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT PUBLIC CORRUPTION BUT ALSO
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO TRIED TO
COVER IT UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DID A REPORT TWO WEEKS
AGO, THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, A
REPORT THAT TALKED ABOUT
POLITICAL INFLUENCE AND
SHENANIGANS GOING ON IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BASED ON
14FBI AGENTS TALKING TO OUR
OFFICE AS WHISTLE BLOWERS.
ONE OF THOSE AGENTS SAID, THIS
IS THE TERM HE USED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF FBI.
SPECIFICALLY WASHINGTON FIELD
OFFICE.
HE SAID IT'S ROTTED TO THE CORE.
WHEN IS THE FBI GOING TO QUIT
INTERFERING WE ELECTIONS?
2016 SPIED ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN AND 2018 THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND 2020
SUPPRESSED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
HUNTER BIDEN STORY AND 2022
RAIDED THE PRESIDENT'S HOME.
91 DAYS BEFORE AN ELECTION.
MAYBE IT'D BE NICE IF THE FBI
AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT STAYED
OUT AND LET WE THE PEOPLE DECIDE
WHO SHOULD REPRESENT US.
>> Sean: TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE AND DEMOCRATS WERE IN
CONGRESS FOR YEARS AND NEVER
DARED INVESTIGATE ANY OF THIS
AND THIS CORRUPTION GOES BACK TO
ONE UP AND BENEFITS ALL OF THEM.
NOW IT'S FINALLY T